[Music]
this legendary Indiana Jones moment also
has a legendary backstory now Steven had
searched the world for the best
swordsman and only et has the
behind-the-scenes details of the scene
that technically wasn't meant to be
we had nothing but fun and Steven and I
just had the most fun sort of bouncing
off each other now
Raiders of the Lost Ark was filmed on a
tight schedule which left no time to be
wasted during production which is why
some creativity was needed when the cast
and crew became ill with dysentery while
on location in Tunisia including Indiana
Jones himself we all finally became ill
except for Stephen of course it arrived
with a full case of SpaghettiOs and
gaffer taped his mouth every time he
took a shower with Raiders I learned how
to compromise creatively more than any
other picture I made since my television
days the sequence where Harrison is
battling the black swordsman and pulls
out the gun and shoots the swordsman was
a compromise that I made on the day that
Harrison wasn't feeling too well the
rest of us sort of stumbled through
hoping for the best and not really
obtaining it
this up as I go and I had a three-page
sequence that George had conceived and I
had conceived with along with George and
Larry about the most definitive whip
against the sword fight
now Stephen had searched the world for
the best swordsman lot of planning had
gone into this fight scene so I went up
to Stephen as soon as I arrived and I
said Stephen won we just shoot this on
[ __ ] and Stephen said my god I was
thinking that too so he took out the gun
shot the man we were day half ahead of
schedule and we moved on to the next
sequence and that was a a good way of
compromising north
[Music]
[Music]
audiences loved the scene so much they
even added a callback in the sequel in
moments like these have helped turn
Indiana Jones into one of the most
iconic franchises of all time obvious
I'm extremely pleased with Indiana Jones
films because of the success that they
generated and to me success is not you
know how financially well they did or
whatever but the fact that people
enjoyed them success to me is people
coming up and saying I really love that
movie you know really you know some of
my favorite things have changed my life
those kinds of things that's those are
the kind of reviews that mean something
to me and Indiana Jones got rave reviews
in in the area of the movie goer I gave
them something Steven gave them
something Harrison gave them something
that was meaningful in their lives I'm
proud of the fact that it has a certain
soul to it I've tried to infuse that in
my movies and and I think ultimately as
time goes on those are the things that
last trust me
[Music]